[Music]
all right so thank you all my name is
Aditya and this talk is titled Goro
translating code to other human
languages and back again I've been
writing JavaScript off and on for like
well my first brushin with javascript
was nearly 20 years ago at this point
but these days my primary language isn't
JavaScript it's actually go so I've been
writing gogo full time for the last
seven years and today I'm gonna be
taking a look at some work that's been
done in NGO and seeing how we might
apply that same work to the JavaScript
world as well so even though my examples
are going to be mostly and go everything
you see today can and should be done in
JavaScript too how many of you speak
English as a second language okay that's
the overwhelming majority here so
worldwide only 5% of the world speaks
English as their first language and only
about 11% speaks English at all so that
means that the majority people who speak
English speak it as their second
language and if this conference were
perfectly representative of the entire
world in every way that means that only
a hundred and sixty-five people out of
this entire conference would be able to
understand this talk and of those all
but 75 would be listening to me speak
and what's for them a foreign language
as we like to say software is eating the
world but also javascript is eating
software I don't just mean that things
are moving to the web which is has
always been JavaScript's platform of
dominance but JavaScript's also being
used in ways that we that we never
really thought of maybe like 20 years
ago
no js' was launched on this very stage
10 years ago at this conference and that
completely changed the way in which we
think in which we think of javascript
javascript is now being used you can use
javascript to write Excel macros try
explaining that to someone in the
mid-90s that you know yes someday that
you're gonna be using live scripts to
write your Microsoft Office macros you
also if you want to do permissioning
logic within within Linux you're going
to be writing JavaScript rules because
you're going to be using Pulkit for that
and pull get execute javascript rules
so technology which includes software is
a powerful enabling force and we have
the if you have the ability to do
amazing things on a global scale using
software thanks to software we're able
to take pictures of a black hole that's
fifty five million light years away we
can treat and cure diseases that would
have been thought chronic or even fatal
just a few decades ago we might not
think of this as achievements of
software specifically but software is
actually the underlying force that's
powering an abling all of these but
software can also be used for some
pretty terrible things as well people
have written software that's used to
enable oppression or to inflict violence
or even commit genocide if we think that
software is a powerful and enabling
force then we need to take a careful
look at who it empowers and who it
enables and what that allows them to do
I have relatives who don't speak English
if one of them came to me and said that
they want to learn to write software
then and asked me for advice and what to
do the first thing I'd say is well you
have to learn English because if you
don't speak English you're not really
going to be able to do much in in the
software all certainly not an
open-source software development if you
know especially if you don't even speak
if you don't even read the Latin script
because your native language uses a
different script altogether that itself
is a barrier so if writing software is
only an option for the 10% of the world
who can speak English that has huge
implications about what it means when we
say that software is a power and
empowering and enabling force so if
javascript wants to be the future of
software development and we think that
software development is going to be is
going to be an enabling force for the
world then we need to make sure that
writing javascript is accessible to
people of all languages not just English
the idea of eliminating natural language
barriers to programming isn't new at all
in fact it's very old Grace Hopper is
one of the first computer scientists and
she wrote the very first compiler for a
high-level programming language right
behind me there's the there's the hall
of computer scientists the pioneers I
should go check out her portrait there
the language that Grace Hopper invented
was called COBOL and she wanted the goal
with that was to have English like
natural language syntax so that business
executives could write code
she got a lot of pushback about this
because engineers thought well you know
if if non engineers can write code this
can put us out of a job but Hopper
actually took this vision even further
why restrict this to English like syntax
you know if it what if engineers who
speak other languages want to be able to
write code as well and she wanted COBOL
to be and I quote a language you can use
to talk to people around the world and
the response she got to that was even
more vitriolic they basically said no
how can we teach American computers to
Rutt to read German programs and that
that wasn't an accident they you know
this wasn't a a question of how it can
be done technically it was very much a
political question this is the 1950s and
so in the US military which is where
hoppers working the fear of a threat
from Germany or Russia was still a huge
a huge fear in people's minds but even
if Hopper hoppers idea was put on the
back burner in the 1950s due to politie
xenophobia and and Cold War politics we
can look at what that means today and
apply it and apply that approach to to
modern languages so this is hopper
speaking about COBOL many years later
she said you know would have thought
that it would be useful to NATO because
they had the common verbs for the things
that they were going to do and the nouns
they just have to have a dictionary for
the things they were referring to you
for inventory control
they'd have common nouns throughout NATO
and they could make a dictionary of
common verbs and translate the program
you could write one in English and you
could translate it and it could go to
the other language no problem you'd have
communication it would be a limited
vocabulary one thing that's interesting
to note here is just that Hopper chose
the imperative mood specifically because
she thought it would be universal to
languages so not all languages
distinguish between past present future
tenses in the same way but languages
generally have a way of commanding
people to do something and COBOL was one
of the languages which popularized the
imperative programming styles and that's
what that's stuck with us to this day
even JavaScript which is has the
capabilities of a functional language we
still usually use imperative imperatives
for the four function names and that's
indirectly a result of this tradition
that Grace Hopper started so let's see
what we get when we take the principles
of Hopper's vision and apply
that to a modern programming language
like JavaScript or go so to answer that
question we can take a look at Goro Goro
is an extension of the go compiler and
tool chain to support Bengali
the name Goro is an idiomatic
translation of the English name go
in a moment I'll you'll see why I chose
go for this example that's for some
technical reasons we'll get into but as
for Bengali well I chose that because
Bengali is it's the language of my
family speaks and you know we're Bengali
and if you talk to big oli people about
our language and culture you'll see very
quickly that we're pretty proud of it
the Bengalis we like to say is the
language that's so beautiful people
literally fought a revolution an entire
war to defend the right to speak it the
United Nations more recently actually
issued a declaration stating that
Bengali was the was the sweetest sound
sounding language in the entire world
but in a more practical note Bengali is
a pretty common language after Hindi
it's the it's the most common language
spoken in India and it's also the
national language of Bangladesh combined
that means that it's the seventh most
widely spoken language in the entire
world there are more native speakers of
Bengali than there are of German and
French combined and Bengali also uses as
you can see here a non Latin script so
it gives us an opportunity to test the
bet the boundaries of what we can do
with Unicode and how how characters get
treated and how they are rendered in
languages outside the ASCII code range
but again nothing that I'm doing here is
unique to Bengali or or to go so if you
speak another language which it seems
like the majority of this room does I'd
encourage you to go home and try to do
this with your own language as well so
this right here is just a simple hello
world written in in standard go even if
you don't you know if you never written
a line of go you can pretty much guess
what it's doing here and this is that
equivalent program that's written in
coral now we've left the identifier
names intact but think all the key words
are now been translated to Bengali and
yes I did not forget true-true is
actually unlike JavaScript true is not a
key word in go and so big based on based
on seeing the previous slide you can
take a guess at what what this program
is doing if you don't
speak Bengali you might not be able to
figure it out from scratch but if you do
this is a whole lot more readable than
what we just saw in the previous slide
but the first challenge we need to do
here is we need to get this program to
run because the go compiler isn't gonna
know what to do with with these keywords
they're not standard go keywords but
here we can take advantage of a nice
trick and this is why we chose go for
this example go source code is all utf-8
so the go compiler has no trouble
dealing with non ASCII characters in
gotengo programs and the go compiler is
bootstrapped it's written in go so that
means that the go compiler is just a go
program so it means that the go compiler
has no trouble dealing with non ASCII
keyword definitions or strings and there
are a few non-alphabetic or the few
checks that ensure that non-alphabetic
or non-latin characters aren't gonna be
used in key words but it turns out that
you can just disable them and nothing
actually goes wrong so if we just
disabled them all we need to do is
extend the mapping that has the strings
that map strings to to the internal
tokens and extend those to include the
Bengali translations of the key words as
well
javascript already has the analogous
concept of transformations and that's
something that's used very heavily in
JavaScript you know with languages like
typescript or also with with polyfills
and it's a little trickier to do this
for reasons of that have to do with
compiler architecture which I'm not
really going to get into but it's still
it's it's fairly similar it's still very
much possible to use this same approach
in JavaScript to translate from one
human language to another or one dialect
of a programming language to another so
having made those changes here's what
that HelloWorld program looks like in
practice
so you can see the program and we're
gonna run it there we go
thank you for remember our goal is to
defragment open-source development not
to fragment it further so we need to
make sure that our code that we're
reading in goro is still interoperable
with code that english-speaking NGO
developers are going to use as well and
we don't have to want to have to
translate every program manually because
that would be infeasible and of course
computers are here to do the heavy
lifting for us
well conveniently for translation go
already has a handy utility for
formatting source code it's called go
format or depending on you pronounce it
go font and mostly we use go format to
prevent bike shedding over arguments
like tabs versus spaces or semicolons
things like that but so instead of
arguing over you know which is the
proper way to indent your code you just
set up your editor or whatever the way
you want and then to render tabs however
you want them to be and then when you
save your code it just gets go formatted
and then it's committed in the standard
form so if I want to use four spaces for
indentation and you want to use to go
format means we can still work together
we don't need to fight about this I'll
just set up my editor to render it but
the width I want and then we don't even
need to know that we have different
indentation preferences because the code
that's committed is still in the
standard form but go format handles a
lot more than that as well because it's
syntax aware so it can do things like
remove unnecessary parentheses and
ensure that it will never change your
code semantics
that's a simpler way of saying that it's
a great way of performing fully
isomorphic translations of source code
and that's exactly what we want here so
all we have to do is extend go format
and and repurpose it for translating
English go go code into bengali or vice
versa and that's what Goro format does
so let's translate that same program
written in Goro back into English
speaking go and run it
so here's the choral program and now we
can format it and we get the English
program again but if you don't believe
me we can actually run it and prove that
it does the exact same thing
there we go we just translated from from
one language to another and back again
[Applause]
there we go so the same way that you
didn't know that I was using four spaces
for tabs and I didn't know that you were
using to go having a having
bi-directional translation layers means
that you don't need to know that I'm
writing my code in English and I don't
need to know that you're writing your
code in German or in Spanish or in
Marathi or whatever language that you
happen to speak we can still work
together and we localize our source code
as a commit hook and then our editor
will just display it for us in the
language that we want as a developer
gorel means that we only need to look at
source code in our own language and as
far as the code is concerned our
language preferences are no more of a
barrier to you and me writing code and
working together then our indentation
preferences are and that's the way it
should be
so we've translated the key words but
you'll notice that we left the we didn't
touch everything so like the package
names and the identifier is those those
we kept in English let's see is there a
way that we can translate those as well
and people there are a lot of debates on
the right ways to choose variable names
but one thing that pretty much everyone
agrees on is that they should be simple
and concise and I'm sorry descriptive
and concise and if you don't speak
English then it's not very descriptive
to have English English code names but
in reality many variable and function
names are already actually highly
structured so we don't need to you know
as as Hopper mentioned we already have
the verbs that we use when we're talking
about our program there's a common
vocabulary so we can take advantage of
that in the translation step as well and
translate these in oops what did this
not there we go so yeah so we have you
know read foo write food then etc these
are common verbs that we'll already use
when we write our JavaScript when you
write JavaScript and even if we don't
translate all of them having that on the
right is a whole lot better it's a whole
lot more descriptive and understandable
than what's on the rest you might not
know what foo means you might not even
be able to you might not even be able to
pronounce that but you can still tell
now that that means that you're going to
be reading something it's some sort of
an access
method so by being just a little bit
more conscious about these conventions
that we're already using we can make our
code that much more accessible to
non-english speakers we might not get
all of these translations for free but
we can still get many of them and that's
a huge step forwards so now the
million-dollar question could we do this
with JavaScript well there are a few
reasons I chose go for this example and
go the source code is required by the
language spec to be in utf-8 and that
means that internally strings and byte
arrays are internally treated as utf-8
as well with an asterisk but as far as
we're concerned it's true JavaScript
though is a little bit trickier because
source code and JavaScript it could kind
of be whatever you want whatever the
interpreter happens to support and as
for the internal representation of
strings that's an even trickier question
if you talk to most people they'll say
it's utf-16 aka wide unicode that's
mostly true except where it's not some
people will also say that it's ucs-2
that's somewhat true except where it's
not the reality is probably best
described like this javascript is some
weird amalgamation of utf-16 and the
ucs-2 internally and it works it's fine
you can deal with it but it makes things
a lot trickier when you're dealing with
non ASCII things outside the ASCII code
points especially when you're dealing
with the actual digging into the actual
internals of the language implementation
itself because you can't you can't rely
on the source encoding because it can be
whatever the interpreter happens to
support and yeah you can't you can't
rely on that and you're dealing with
code points that are that are far
outside the ASCII code range so you
can't you need to be able to handle more
than one byte at a time in your keywords
a lot of implementations particularly
things that are implemented in C they're
gonna struggle with that so could we do
this in JavaScript I mean honestly I
think so I mean it's definitely not as
easy as as it isn't go like I'd have
outlined some of the challenges there
but it's definitely possible
that said one of my friends who's a very
diehard JavaScript programmer you may
know them she told me that the best way
to get job
script developers to write something is
to convince them that it can't be done
in JavaScript her exec where is there
that if you tell them that they can't do
this in JavaScript and within an hour of
your talk finishing there'll be at least
three packages on NPM which do that
thing so I'm gonna go ahead and tell you
that this cannot be done in JavaScript
and I'm gonna bet that you all cannot
prove me wrong so we've now we've done
all of the I would say the source code
itself but there's more to programming
and more to making programming
accessible as well because you have to
talk about the users and the users
include developers who are using
developer tooling as well error messages
are a big part of that no js' actually
does a pretty good job with this by
abstracting the way that messages are
presented from the from the internals of
it so javascript actually already does I
would say well some platforms of
JavaScript does like maybe 70% of the
work that you would need for this go is
an approach to error handling that's
different from most languages but if
you've actually written JavaScript
you're probably still familiar with it
because in JavaScript you can't use
accessors - sorry you can't use
exception handling - for error handling
within a callback because it's
asynchronous code instead you have to
pass in error values and have to operate
on those values go actually just does
the exact same thing but it does it for
all code whether it's asynchronous or
synchronous and in go to use javascript
terminology basically the all errors are
an object that happens to have a dot
ever method on it and that dot error
method is guaranteed to return a string
that's the only thing that you're
guaranteed to know about an error is
that one his specific method is present
and it will always return a string if
it's not if it's not null and that
applies without a plot that that's a
property that means it's very powerful
but it means that that message then
needs to be accessible to people who
don't speak English because whoops well
what happened here
because as developers we've all
struggled with cryptic error messages
this first one is not from JavaScript
it's actually from Java because but it's
my favorite because I've been using it
so long as an example of a terrible
error message then I've actually
forgotten what it means it is a real
error message but if you know what it
means tell me because I've it's been
years I've forgotten but JavaScript
isn't immune either the second one is
from JavaScript and if you write
JavaScript a lot you probably have an
idea of what that means and what the
error is but if you've never written
JavaScript you know this is your first
time carrying that error it's not really
so clear what you need to do there to
fix it and certainly if you don't speak
English because the only thing that's
worse than a cryptic error message is a
cryptic error message in a language that
you can't even understand so translating
error messages is a good starting point
because not only are they finite in
number but translating them will have a
huge impact on the developers that
you're interacting with and they're the
easiest to solve technically because we
can rely on existing localization
strategies and this is where I said that
nodejs does a good job of making this
abstraction available we just don't all
we just don't have that fully for all
languages we're not taking advantage of
that we're certainly not taking
advantage of it across the JavaScript
ecosystem but javascript already has
lots of localization libraries that will
provide variants of of textual strings
in a designated locale they'll assist
with things like pluralization and and
and all that stuff and all you need to
do is just reference a lookup table and
that can be done by a computer and you
can present it to the user in in in the
language that they're going to be able
to understand so we've talked about a
lot of we've talked about a lot of
different things so far and there are a
lot of steps that we could take to
including non-english speakers more in
JavaScript development making tool
chains for translating code to other
languages like what we saw here with
Goro that's just one of them and there's
more as well like I don't have time
today to talk about the some of the more
community aspects like documentation how
do you translate documentation and more
importantly how do you make sure that
that documentation stays in sync between
across languages how do you make things
like mailing lists or even meetups and
conferences like this how do you make
those accessible to people of all who
speak any language not just people who
happen to speak English I don't have
time to go into all those details today
but I've spoken about some of these
challenges that in the past so if you're
interested you can
check that out or you know come find me
afterwards but of course that means that
not ever not all the stuff is technical
but if you are not all this stuff
requires rolling up your sleeves and
writing code but some of it does and if
anyone's interested in going home and
doing this with JavaScript and with
another language like what Koro does for
for go please you know guy all means go
ahead and prove me wrong prove me that
wrong when I say that it can't be done
in JavaScript but others are
straightforward and more low-tech they
involve the ways that we operate as a
community we're really just scratching
the surface here but for any of this
stuff to happen for any of this to be
possible we need to commit ourselves to
doing it we need to remember that 95% of
the world doesn't speak English as their
first language and 89% of the world
doesn't speak English fluently at all
thanks to JavaScript dominance over the
web over the years that means that you
know if there is a language that has
been spoken and is being written today
by by active users and if this be it's
basically a certainty that at some point
that language is being used alongside
javascript that javascript is handling
that language in some capacity that's
that's a virtual certainty just because
of how widely used JavaScript is across
the web and how powerful the web has
been in transforming people's lives not
just in english-speaking countries or
but really all around the world so it
means that there's really no language
that's as well-suited as JavaScript is
to being used by the entire world not
just by people who speak English and we
have an opportunity to bridge this
language divide to make hoppers vision a
reality
in a way that no other programming
language has ever been able to do before
so let's do that let's make JavaScript a
programming language that's truly
accessible to everyone no matter what
language you happen to speak thank you
[Applause]
[Music]